what is like and now i'm gonna ask you
parenting advice if that's okay because
i you know i'm
i i always i talk about this with you
when i see you
um
what do you guys do to keep the kids
safe on social there's one thing you did
that really really spoke to me something
about the comment section
um
tell me about that because i'm very
interested
yeah it's different for the three kids
that were in you know of our five that
are in that picture that everyone has
different rules about social media um we
we don't do one-size-fits-all parenting
and we certainly don't do
one-size-fits-all about social media so
when zaire who is one of our oldest he's
now 20. um when he turned 16 all he
wanted was his own instagram so when we
but when we set it up we set it up
through my husband's account so we could
see
his dms we were all up and through his
dms and let me tell you if as much as
folks were like euphoria is not
realistic let me tell you that show
euphoria was all up and through my
child's comments um
pretty accurate for teens scary yes i
know but if you can get into those dm's
try but like with ziya
we she can only um see comments from
people that she follows so unless she
follows you you cannot leave a comment
but for kavia obviously she can't read
and for us with cob it was important for
us to show a free black girl in all of
her moods whether her whether you know
her hair is done not done you know
whether she's got the cutest outfit on
or she's still in her pajamas on you
know a saturday evening um we wanted
people to see what free black girl hood
looks like and we felt that it was
important um for you know we made people
such a part of our our our heartbreak
with our fertility journey that when kav
arrived there was so much joy and she
represents so much positivity and hope
to so many people we wanted people to
see
what her freedom looks like
i love your style i really do i love it
um okay well speaking of kids oh my gosh
i can't even stand it the cheaper buy
the dozen remake reboot
i mean this is so
fun
um is it true
that like dwayne
and zach
may have known each other or may not
have known each other what what they
just met on the carpet last night and
there's actual footage of them meeting
you know after this press tour where
zach you know said on ellen that he had
no idea who dwayne was and then when he
looked him up he was like oh goodness um
i gotta get in shape uh but yeah they
finally met on the carpet last night and
and both of my husbands um got to got to
you know meet and they hugged they
hugged it out they brought it out um but
yeah it was it was cute
[Music]